foreign
passengers for flight ka29 please make
their way to gate B15
good morning everyone this is Captain
Robin Allen speaking flights on today is
6 hours 54 minutes
[Music]
operation has commenced phones tablets
plane is under control
you need to see this Plainfield of
course
someone is calling for help
[Music]
family
loved ones we got one job to do right
now it just came through for them I got
a message from the plan that says
incident on board what exactly does your
dad do for a living it's difficult to
explain Sam's the best at handling it
the negotiation
[Music]
there are 200 people on this flight
if they try something and then this
plane goes down I don't get home to my
family
let me make you an offer
I've been handed demands it's all going
wrong in the first hour imagine an X6
we need to get a message to the whole
plane
we just need to be ready
there's other stuff going down five
passengers on that plane do not exist
it's a network running all across Europe
so then we're an incoming missile
[Music]
looking for us walk down
I could tell you it's not going to be us
[Music]